so cost of living continues to increase
in many parts of the United States and I
told you a couple weeks ago about the
study where earning minimum wage a
worker working full time could not
afford a two-bedroom apartment in any of
the 50 states in the United States of
America and we talked about many of the
issues on which Democrats and
Republicans are the same or too similar
on the issue of the minimum wage there's
a really big difference between
democrats and republicans democrats have
been having a debate about twelve or
fifteen dollars per hour as the target
for the minimum wage and they've settled
on $15 per hour republicans on the other
hand seemingly emboldened by the
stunning and competence of donald trump
are lowering the minimum wage in many
states so let me set it up for you Trump
scandal after scandal real news making
the u.s. a laughingstock around the
world as we talked about earlier today
Republican legislation at the federal
level that's a disaster which is also
real news the attempt to replace the
Affordable Care Act with a disaster to
cut Medicaid horrible tax reform
building this wall with Mexico that has
low support and would not even really
solve our problem with immigration the
travel ban really long list and also
real news relevant and at the state
level there are disasters going on that
are not making national headlines
because understandably there's so much
going on and Republicans have been
successfully working to lower the
minimum wage that businesses are allowed
to pay workers in a number of states
Missouri Missouri overturned a st. Louis
law that raised the city's minimum wage
to $10 an hour the new law now in
Missouri is that cities and counties
simply can't have higher minimum wages
than the state minimum wage so in st.
Louis the minimum wage is down from ten
dollars an hour to seven dollars and
seventy cents an hour in March in Iowa
Republicans rolled back mandatory pay
increases in certain jurisdictions in
other states lawsuits have been used for
example a few months ago in Kentucky the
state Supreme Court overturned a
Louisville ordinance raising the minimum
wage to nine bucks an hour they
determined that it violated the
a constitution in Maine Republicans with
the help of some Democrats actually
ended up allowing the hourly wage for
tipped employees to be decreased to only
$3.75 an hour and bear in mind that
these increased wages were very low
right even ten bucks an hour in st.
Louis if you work 40 hours a week at ten
bucks an hour and take no vacation all
year meaning 52 weeks a year you're
making under 21 thousand dollars and
once again yes Democrats and Republicans
are similar on way too many issues on
some issues Democrats and Republicans
could not be more different and there
there's been a debate among the
Democrats which I think is also thinking
too small
do we want to go with $15 an hour should
it be twelve and Dems one and fifteen
Hillary Clinton one at 12 what what's
the implication of one versus the other
not an amazingly lavish idea to begin
with st. Louis however thanks the
Republicans has gone from $10 an hour to
7 dollars and 70 cents an hour stunning
and let's be clear that's not
conservative either I mean there's
legitimate point to be make for the
conservative ideology you know society
is changing and we need to adapt to
those changes but let's be careful about
how we do that that's not what this is
this is regressive we had this plan in
place for the minimum wage to go up in
these cities and they're literally
reversing it and people are accounting
on those pay raises when they maybe sign
up for loans it would happen well you
will hear from the right that when you
raise the minimum wage it's dangerous at
the macroeconomic level because if you
raise the cost of labor businesses will
buy less of it and thus unemployment
will go up and it is true that one of
the effects of a higher minimum wage can
be that companies have more incentive to
automate for example although many
companies are looking to do that anyway
or they have reason to raise prices for
whatever product or service they produce
and that it also has the effect of
increasing productivity for workers
since they're being paid more but there
are lots of really good results for
increasing the minimum wage you lower
turnover for example having to find new
workers is really expensive for
businesses if people
getting paid more they're less likely to
quit another major advantage to a higher
minimum wage is you're increasing the
purchasing power of the population and
if you look at the net effect of a
minimum wage increase that is reasonable
right we're not talking about $400 an
hour the net effect is positive on the
economy now it's not a black and white
thing right you hear from the right if a
higher minimum wage is good set the
minimum wage to $400 an hour don't fall
for that no one is suggesting that
that's not an equilibrium minimum wage
given the cost of living in American
society no one is suggesting that and
this is just going to be a bigger and
bigger issue over time with automation
and continued offshoring or even the
destruction of manufacturing and other
types of jobs transportation we need to
actually be thinking about universal
basic income and I'm not going to go
into my whole spiel about that now but
that's an increased issue when we talk
about 770 versus $10 we need we need a
paradigm shift we just have to keep our
priorities in order to especially
because Republicans are trying to pass
their health care plan right now and
that's filled with tax cuts that would
primarily benefit the rich then when
they come back from the congressional
recess in September that's when they
plan to take on tax reform and that will
be filled with plenty of more tax cuts
and hopefully it will still be scandal
after scandal and it won't even be
discussed the way that it's basically
been dead for at this point a couple of
months